プーペース早くねえ案が超超超音も2ギガ max マヨネーズマック生に大学な水元
切るカロリー
した
入ってスカイすぎだろう
ご案内週間前ぐらいに僕がのペアのギガ max の力からペアの授業 max を
食べたばっかりなのにもう新しい j max が出ました
こちらベアンがちょっと場も2ギガ max マネー妻です
あーやーいやマジで速いよないや
ありがとうございますユーチューバー時にはネタをいただいてありがとうございます
今日窓食べてなくて良かったり全然消えますなぁ今回のポイントとしては監査はないと
そこはすごいありがたいですか出さないが助かるし私ですね
ギーマヨラーみたいなところあるんですよマヨネーズがないとやだみたいな人間じゃ
ないんですけども前に
ず比較的好きなんで多分
食べます取るにしても出すの早いんですね僕が恐れているのはこれが覚えてこのマヨ
ネーズってやっぱ向坂油というか何かと
胸いっぱいになる味だと思うんで話してみたいして74キロ3分の前に絶句さも来た時
に彼高遠藩も凄いけどわかんないんですけど拒否反応が出た瞬間僕は終わりですやこれ
迷うなぁからするとか万代1品でしょういいえにマヨネーズ教
熱おけるわけですからねパンマン冷蔵というわけで作っていきましょう
ん
お手がいた
2のソース早くハゲっはバー音も前でふ
これなんで普通のサイズを出せなかったんだろう次つい day 4家もあるん
毎回聞いてるだけでもやばいんじゃなあああ
ん
うん
追い切り今
アーチャーやめろお前
ウォッチャー
そうそうそう
まーすっかけるフォーマン者らシミバッハダラー
ねー
一部映像が乱れてしまいました大変失礼いたしました
じゃあさっそく作っていきましょういやもう相変わらず物量がやばすぎますねそうした
けど普通のプラグギガ max になるんですけど
さらにここにこの町で計マヨネーズ落ち込んでいるわけでば
ガッツリ出てきますと水山八枚フェズ
いや oo やつねえめちゃくちゃマヨネーズが入ってるですがこれがきっと美味しい
んでしょ
いや普通に美味さだとこれ焼きそばで普通に行くより甘いチョコ
相次いでできましたーーーでここで私は思いました私は今まで数々の大食いをやってき
ました
畑でも食べ味が max もいろいろため結構で食べる速度3箇所に
比べたら相当早くなったし食べる量がめちゃくちゃ増えたと思うんですよ今日はとある
大物ユーチューバーとどちらが先にマヨネーズ max を食べるか勝負したいと思い
ます
誰かわかりますかこちらの重湯千葉ですどうぞ
ブーブー明けですかあっあんっああんってトッピングあちょっブーバーちっちゃかった
よねーちゃんっていうん
ダメですよそんな釣っちゃいますよ
どうじゃないのに私肇社長 ob のイメージありますよね
むしろ顔緑苑東頃がどっこいこの久しぶりに会って僕限らずの応用してきてですね
食べれ速度が昔と比べて飛躍的に上がったんですよ今日はその進化したオレオとミク
さんに見せればなぁと思いましてね感動しますねぼくめっちゃ早かったらもう混同する
私へこのあ
てない1年ぐらいで培った進化を今こそお見せしましょう
そんなに変わんねーだろいやもう食べるよええこれはほ宿
ウェイ
クィア素材やでもねと一理事は早いですからね食べるのまあそもそも味お茶でレビュー
するのを大事ですからね
そうはいでは行きます till dawn
さあいただきまいただきまーす
ウイーン jal なぁ
あった
マヨネーズのうんいいですすごいそんなつくねえだろふ
うんもうマイルドかけ焼きそば ufo 年前マヨビームのかかっている感じ
一番不味かったペア向けない
それが少なめで美味しかったのでずるいぞそう言って話してさあ
タイムうわぁうめぇ貼り方がうわぁ
ぞいやわかるだか打つ際は無理にどうせくれないんだからさ
いやークレーンのあー作る真面目
ございバー
水たくさん飲んだ9分はいの分くださいえっ
マヨネーズ2
まよな
マヨラーじゃねえええへんなのここで迷わずないのが裏目に出ますか
いっ
ua
知っています
ん
割るん
ザイヤー6分半分
ね絶対食えんわこれ
絶対行くよまん
これから不審だフリートがするんだって絶っっっ対行くよウォッチ
ん a
うん
右派塾ね食えるようになったんですが頑張ったんだ
すげーもやっぱりこういうのって
で目には勝てんなゲームじゃ b
[音楽]
me
あっはっ